au zaïre les rebelles ont investi la
troisième ville du pays
kisangani menaçant ainsi directement 90
mille réfugiés leur chef laurent désiré
kabila fort de son succès n'entend plus
parler de cessez-le-feu son prochain
objectif il l'a dit et la prise de la
capitale kinshasa et le départ du
président mobutu
isabelle staes laurent désiré kabila
savoure sa victoire
il est désormais le maître à kisangani
et dans tout l'est du zaïre devant les
journalistes toujours le même message
l'offensive continue nous avançons et
nous devons maintenant libéré tout le
pays
jusqu'où ira laurent désiré kabila
rien ne semble arrêter la progression de
ses troupes avec la conquête de
kisangani
les rebelles sont en position de force
et leur chef un interlocuteur désormais
incontournable il sans gagner c'est la
base stratégique de l'armée zaïroise
troisième ville du pays
elle verrouiller l'accès vers la
capitale kinshasa l'armée régulière en
déroute les rebelles progressent sur
tous les fronts avec un objectif
lubumbashi au sud dans la riche province
minière du shaba la visite hier à goma
de l'émissaire des nations unies mohamed
sahnoun est restée vaine
kabila refuse tout cessez le feu mais il
ya urgence sur la rive du fleuve zaïre
160 mille réfugiés à famille puis les
malades sont coupés du monde
je pense très fortement que
l'humanitaire est à l'extrême limite de
sa capacité d'intervention que doit
faire la communauté internationale doit
prendre ses responsabilités elle sait
que ils sont au bord du fleuve elle de
savoir comment ça va se passer sinon bah
nous porterons touché à croix
lacroix eux la porte déjà ils sont 160
milles en danger de mort
si la communauté internationale
n'intervient pas rapidement